la piste aux étoiles le pot rempli d'eau
dans lequel nous dit ni sont fermés
enchaîné la magie les dresseurs de faux
avec des pièces ayant servi au tournage
de fiction comme la cage du film des
deux frères de jean jacques annaud
vous êtes ici au royaume de la pantomime
et des saltimbanques
alors là on est devant et un espace
dédié à achille zavatta achille zavatta
l'auguste le plus célèbre au monde avec
est mort en 1993 et il ya une belle
collection qui a été qui m'a été prêté
par sa femme annick qui habite pas très
loin du musée tout ce qui est présenté
dans le musée c'est vraiment que des
pièces uniques un camp pas retenu
vraiment à des gens célèbres qui ont une
histoire qui ont vécu c'est pas la
maquette du cirque jean richard c'est à
dire le chef jean richard a jamais eu
trois pistes c'est à la maquette de ses
rêves
est ce un ami à lui qui lui a qui lui a
fabriqué pour lui faire plaisir
pour sa réouverture le musée du cirque
et inquiets d'une nouvelle pièce
encore une fois unique ce costume donc
de deux clowns date de 1895 et on en a
la preuve puisque on a fait des
recherches quand on me l'a offert avant
1900 les costumes c'était ce style de
c'était ce style avec avec du drap
choses comme ça un peu différente
couleur 7 6 la sela 6 2 richard dit
junior que j'ai récupéré chez un ami
maziz magicien cesse appartenait à son
grand père et puis ben pareil 7,6
également l'autre version vient de du
côté de rouen chez un ami magicien
également qui m'a appelé en me disant
qu'à mon père avait une scie pour faire
la femme coupée en deux elle est allée
dans le garage en train de pourrir
si tu la veux je te la donne quoi je me
trouve ici dans la cage qui a servi au
tournage du film
roselyne et les lions de jean jacques
beineix il y as devant moi le yéti
l'homme des neiges mais je n'irai pas le
voir ces merveilles et bien d'autres
encore vous pourrez les re découvrir dès
samedi
bon et pépette du joli